CNN even covered the restrictive voting
law that is going on in Georgia that no
one can figure out while telling us that
they're getting record turnout it is the
first major election in Georgia under a
restrictive new voting law that's not
stopping record numbers of people from
casting their ballots early
I can see how people have brain damage
if you watch CNN too long right like if
you watch MSNBC you're just completely
insane and that's why I always call it
the televised mental institution but do
you get what they're doing on CNN on one
hand they're telling you there's record
turnout all sorts of people showing up
and voting nobody's being turned away
but now the restrictive voting laws I
think it includes something like having
an ID saying who you are that sort of
thing endless driveless nonsense but
that's corporate media running cover for
the Democrats so if the result isn't
what they want we'll roll into four
years of oh you are allowed to question
the results of the elections because we
got Republicans in charge and they
obviously are the bad guys so we better
question results of course uh here's a
tweet from Molly Hemingway who I met a
couple weeks ago at an event in Florida
she was talking about what's going on
here in Florida and she wrote
interesting answers from both Democrat
demmings Val demings who's running here
in Florida for Senate against Marco
Rubio Democrat Deming doesn't say
whether she will accept election results
Republican Rubio says he will accept
election results because of Florida's
great election laws so even think about
this here in Florida there is nobody I
have not heard and I'm I'm out there
okay I'm out there in Florida
I have not heard anyone saying we are
having any issues with voting we have an
extremely secure system DeSantis has has
done everything possible to make sure
that all of the people in Southwest
Florida will be able to vote despite all
the wreckage that they're still trying
to fix up from the hurricane like
there's no there is no uh feeling of oh
there's Shenanigans going on here in
Florida so Rubio is coming out coming
out right now and saying hey we're good
to go if I lose I lose if I win I win we
are good to go because I trust the
system demings who is not going to win
by the way but she can now they can just
seed the craziness with the Democrats
well I don't know she has no evidence no
reason to think there's someone send me
something someone if someone can find
some story somewhere about how Florida
is hiding votes and is stopping black
people from voting and all of the stuff
please I'll gladly cover it tomorrow
would you do that for me